salut mon petit ma croûte comme rim rate
mais la question pourquoi tu parles plus
tu es malade qu'est ce qui t'arrive
je sais pas ce qui m'arrive dès que je
parle j'ai la voix de gilles verdez tata
prix des médicaments a appris un truc
banon s'est pris quelque chose mais j'ai
mal à la gorge
on dit à quelqu'un j'entends dire qu'il
ya quelqu'un à tous à tous à tous et toi
à tous à tous odudu je suis rentrée
n'est salut merci pour l'accueil ça va
qu'est ce qui lie femme actuelle
qu'est-ce qu'il prend à quoi j'ai fait
tous les tests je m'ennuie t'ai jamais
là toujours par monts et par vaux bien
je m'occupe et alors qu'est ce que dany
tu as jamais le croire quoi apparemment
je suis creed origen
là le maître arrive et l'unicité des
caisses
heureusement c'était la goutte à l abri
sont pas tant les numéros avant mon si
aucun saut sa masse et voilà ça y est on
a vite bertrand un dîner danser y aurait
plus qu'à ses blagues à lui tassé la
jeunesse ali charge de qu'on voit ça va
calme toi c'est ça tu a tout gagné je me
casse tu verras plus qu'un c'est foutu
le verra encore parce qu'ils n'étaient
pas bien qu'elle ne soit connue
calme-toi